okay first of all i want to know how
y'all sleeping
how are things
i mean when we started this project yeah
i was reading the script i was reading
the comics and i was listening to
audible and
things weren't going well for me
so i had to give one of them up so the
audible had to go
because my dreams were terrifying
um
yeah like i read the dino scene
i read that and i'd read the script and
yeah it it was too much oh my little
head i keep trying to find morpheus in
my dreams to go like come on dude like
like we should talk about this like
i think like am i doing it okay
[Music]
the fan base for the comic books they're
very passionate were there any nerves
getting involved with this an enormous
amount it was terrifying um but
i am one of those fans like i care about
this so much and so i have a small
insight into how they're feeling because
i feel it um and
i
i think that
the responsibility i felt for
their dreams of who morpheus was um was
not dissimilar to the responsibility
that he has for the dreams of everyone
yeah um and so that was a small way into
how to play it hmm
yeah
um i think that
i mean yeah felt pressure nerves all of
the emotions
but i think it was so grounding having
neil yeah there like the creator there
knowing that
you've got this part you've got on this
role because the creator of this
magnificent magical amazing i mean i
just love it
literature has gone you can do that
wrong yes and i'm like me can i okay all
right if you're saying that i can do it
and we've just got amazing scripts and
this
like incredible world that has been
created so
i was like
okay let's do this so yeah yeah
your voice in this
how did you
settle on this voice how did you come up
with it how did you pick it land it
uh
dude
it's a great question because it did
took forever i mean the strange thing
about
the graphic novel is that we're so
familiar with how people look what they
say but we don't hear them and so it's
it's it's kind of like you're like i
know everything about him but then
you're like
what does he sound like um and so the
first thing i did was i asked neil and
neil said very specifically that he
should be
the voice that is inside of your head
and the voice that guides you to sleep
and the voice that kind of
carries you through your dreams and that
and that voice obviously has to have
authority and maybe some danger to it
but it also has to be
seductive because you want to go with
him
[Music]
okay
i'm coming with you
what would you say to the fans that are
you know have an opinion about
characters that were in the comic books
being specific genders or races but in
this it switched
i'd just say this is an adaptation
that neil gaiman is the creator of the
the mind behind it that you know
and i just say it's another adaptation
you've got the original there you've got
the comics it's magnificent we love them
and this is just another adaptation
for the modern world that we live in and
just like lean into it enjoy it because
it's magnificent and
it it it's so
thrilling and liberating and it's kneels
yeah it's huge yeah
the reason we love
sam and the books is because we love his
mind yeah and sound man the show is his
mind and so
let's go on the new journey that neil
gaiman has created yeah it's hard to
describe if you're not a fan of the
comic books or no of the comic books
it'd be hard to describe this show to
someone at least i struggled so do you
guys have three words
three words
you only got threes
you've only got three tom
um
[Laughter]
you must watch
um
the human condition
oh
spicy
i went there and i feel liberated and
i'm really proud of myself
thank you guys